♪ Keke, do you love me ♪
♪ Are you riding ♪
♪ Said you'd never ever
leave from beside me ♪
♪Cus I want ya, and I need ya,
and I'm down for ya always. ♪
(plane engine)
- Hey!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat music)
Is there anything I can help with?
- Well I don't know.
I don't know
- Yeah, fire away.
- [Man] You just ask the question,
I was getting ready to say,
what do you think about the agents
and stuff like that, talent agencies.
- I think if you like,
this is how I think.
The world's crazy now.
When I go on stage and like,
this is the best year to be alive,
people are like "Aah
Trump" and I understand it
there is plenty of fucked up shit.
You made a fucking video,
do you know what I mean?
People don't get it, like
that's not how it went down.
Like, you know, I'm old,
you had to move to fucking Hollywood,
wait tables, and be the
one black dude they picked
out of everyone there.
It's real wild, and like
if you're a youngster,
you don't have context, you don't know.
But I've got it real good
'cus I'm old enough to know
but young enough to still
want to do something about it.
And then you've got people that are like,
this is why 80 year old's
are like "these fucking",
you know?
So couple of things,
if you really want to have
like a Netflix special
or like straight up you're like, fuck it,
I want to make like Friday,
you need a fucking agent.
- [Shiggy] Yeah.
- Like we can make real
money being like us.
But if you want to make a fucking movie,
you need William Morris
or CA, UTA, you do.
- WME?
- WME.
- Yeah.
- Definitely.
- You do, for now, I believe that.
- [Shiggy] Okay.
- [Man] What do you think that they bring,
they bring, I guess the
production into it and everything.
- They're gatekeepers,
they don't bring anything.
But the keys.
- [Man] Oh that makes sense.
- Right?
- [Shiggy] Yeah.
- They put him together
with someone who really
knows how to make movies, they hit off,
and they make a Beverly
Hills Cop, let's go.
Right? It's just kind of like that,
it's just kind of crazy like that.
If that's what you want to do.
If you want to do like, that's
what's crazy about music,
how far you can now go, in film you can't.
You can't point me to the
movie that's like the big
blockbuster on YouTube yet.
I believe that will happen.
- [Shiggy] Yeah.
I believe the same way Netflix happened,
I believe you could wait
and make your own comedy,
raise money, make something amazing,
and in 12, 15 years I
think what Netflix is,
is going to be long-tail,
there'll be more of them.
Things like them, the way
internet works, right?
Like even the way people watch the shit,
I don't know if you saw but I'm
obsessed with garage saling,
people are watching my shit,
people are taking pictures
of them watching it,
they're watching it on their main TV
'cus everybody now
knows how to put YouTube
from their phone to their
TV, like Grandma doesn't,
but you do and so when that happens,
well then let's go, you can
do your own stand-up special.
Rent out a fucking
place, have people come,
film it and you can do your own raw.
And you've got a big enough
audience, I'd pay $3.99 for you.
You know, that kind of shit.
So it's all coming, the
problem is your moments now.
- [Shiggy] Yeah exactly.
- Right? So you have to give
up some of the money, right?
To continue it, if
that's what you wanna do.
Or you keep building momentum,
you know I'm watching you,
you keep trying it, what's
great about being creative is,
you could think of something tomorrow,
post it and you've got a shot.
And I do think this, I do
think if you have a second meme
of real scale it puts you in
a totally different place.
- [Shiggy] Yeah I know.
- God forbid, which means please God,
you can do something in the
next year that goes again,
like really goes.
- [Shiggy] Really goes, yeah.
- Then you're going to have
some real fuckin' leverage.
Then you're going to hear shit like,
you remember Will I Am was the
Creative Director of Intel,
you get another one for real for real?
People are going to be like,
this guy is a genius, you know?
You agree with that Andy?
- [Andy] He's already genius.
- Why did you like that so much,
'cus I always like how you
react 'cus you're smart.
- [Andy] It was funny.
- Okay, got it (laughs)
So I think that's, you know?
- [Shiggy] That's it, yeah.
- My advice? Throw a curve ball.
Instead of doing another dance or meme,
do like a pop up event.
- [Andy] Pop up shop.
- Mhm, throw a curve ball.
Go in your creative mind with the crew,
do something that isn't expected.
Like, I don't know,
swim across the Hudson,
you know what I mean?
- [Shiggy] Something I
wouldn't even expect.
- Just something like,
we're all sitting here,
people that admire your work and be like,
okay he's going to do some
sort of dance or meme,
or act out something,
throw somebody for a loop.
- [Shiggy] To throw off the people
that are expecting something different.
- That's how you win, right?
- [Man] Will Smith tried to
do (mumbles) a jumping off.
- Well Will did extremely well and
that's a good thing to bring up.
What Will did extremely well
is he deployed humility,
and said fuck it, I milk
the shit out of getting
paid 25 million for the same
movie 53 times in a row,
and now nobody gives a fuck about me,
and I'm going to go into
where everybody gives a fuck,
but I'm still fucking Will Smith,
I'm talented and funny and the best,
and I'm just gonna live in that world.
And that's why he wins, right?
And by the way Will Smith's
an interesting comp for me,
like I always know I'm gonna
win because I've one skill set.
I give a fuck about audience,
I know what's going on in culture,
I know what the fuck I'm doing.
So cool, you want to go to Mars?
We'll just start, I'll figure it out.
I'll always have another act.
- [Shiggy] Shit.
- Two things, I would really give a fuck
about being strategic
about your next move.
But I wouldn't be crippled by it either.
- [Shiggy] Don't be.
- You don't need to, if
you put too much pressure
that I've got to nail this next thing,
you're going to get in the wrong mindset.
You need to look at Will Smith.
I think Will Smith did
everything wrong for six years.
Made movies nobody wanted to watch.
But then did one right
thing and we're like "oh!"
Britney's back is always amazing.
One of the things that
happens to guys like you,
at least from my
observation, I don't know you
and everybody's got different psyche but,
you get crippled, of
course 'cus now you're
trying to be perfect on the next move.
It's why people's second albums suck.
You like that, right?
Like it's so cliche, right?
The amount of people, that's why Bigge,
I loved him so much,
oh shit this is Fire 2
you are the best, you know!
Everybody looking at Boyd
who's so deep in music.
Second albums are tough,
first album's are easy.
I'm going to tell you my
story, now you're famous.
And everyone's like where that's fire.
That's the biggest reason
that I think Tee Grizley
is going to win, that one sentence
that he said to me in studio,
I just rap about actual
things that happen to me.
So I wouldn't, you know
- [Shiggy] Wouldn't overthink it.
- You know what it is?
I'm really good at public speaking,
I'm not nervous but there's still
an energy one minute before I go on.
And if I lose that then I'm ghost, right?
So I start this meeting
I was like like 'oh shit,
you've got to get your next", you know?
But then I'm telling you
on the flip, in the end,
you do some lame thing and
everyone says that's lame,
good, come out with something great.
Little Wayne did a fucking rock album.
Right and I always bring
that up because I'm trying
to remind people, everybody's got an L.
- [Man] That was a terrible album.
- That's my point, that's my point.
Which is like, he's the fucking best.
And he did a fucking, good for him.
I have so much love, I don't know him,
but I have so much for
him because he did that.
He needed to get that off.
- [Shiggy] Yeah, sometimes
you get it all just to
- That's a real creative.
If you weezy it and you do that, you know?
No, he did it when he had
leverage and I get it.
But you need to be thoughtful,
but you need to not
overthink your creativity
it's how you got here in the first place.
- [Shiggy] Yeah, just doing regular shit.
- Just doing regular shit,
that's a real good way to put it.
- [Shiggy] (laughs) That's a fact though.
- That's what it is.
And now you've got nothing
but fucking voices,
everybody's got a fucking opinion.
- [Man] That's how I'm
feeling about Kevin Hart.
Because Kevin Heart, he...
I used to like him, when
he's doing the old thing.
Not saying he's doing too clean,
but too like-
- He's going for money.
- Yeah but...
- And honestly, you guys
are gonna go for it too.
- [Shiggy] Eventually.
- Man if everything went perfect,
and you're getting $32 million
to make a lame ass movie,
you all gonna look at each other
and be like...
- [Both] Yeah.
(laughing)
- You know. You know.
- Yeah.
- Like the good thing is what...
It's funny, Kevin and
I, also like you and I,
I DM him a lot.
I saw him on Netflix the other day.
We got real love for each other.
I don't consume shit, so I don't really...
I know he's doing big movies,
that have to be vanilla,
to be as big as they are.
But I don't know what he's
doing with his standup.
I did see one a year ago,
what I think comedians
have, that's amazing,
is go get paid and do 15 million
on a movie that's vanilla,
for white America,
and then go kill it on stage.
Fucking Bob Saget.
Bob Saget's a gangster,
do you know who that is?
- [Shiggy] Yeah, yeah.
- The Full House guy.
- Full House dad.
- He's fucking "Full House" dad,
he's inappropriate on stage.
- Yeah he curse a lot.
- Not even curse a lot,
he's like inappropriate.
(laughing)
He's inappropriate.
I curse every minute, he's inappropriate.
He's politically incorrect.
And people come in there like,
"Oh honey, let's go see Bob Saget,
he's funny on "Full House"."
Like getting into fucking some shit.
(laughing)
- [Shiggy] That's the good thing about is-
- And so that's where I
think comedy has such...
I wish I was a comedian.
- Yeah.
- As a businessman, I
can't get away with stuff.
I would be unstoppable if
I can be under comedian.
- [Shiggy] Yeah you can say certain shit.
- Yeah you can do whatever
the fuck you want.
- You can say certain
shit, do certain shit.
- 100%, I like them a lot.
So you just need to...
The one other thing I'll tell you,
that I want to tell you,
'cus I knew we were getting together,
I don't want to forget,
make shit.
'Cus what you're about to
do is try to get perfect.
And you're not gonna make.
- [Shiggy] Oh, what you mean by that?
- Put out content, try
to, just keep doing shit.
- [Shiggy] Yeah, you right.
- Just keep doing shit.
- Yeah you're right.
- Everybody fucking does something
and then they get put on,
and they change the thing
that got them to put on.
- [Shiggy] Yeah you're right.
- Because now you got eyes.
"What will Kevin Durant think about this?"
(laughing)
- [Man] Yeah I can't do this.
- Now who's looking...
Yeah you're right.
- Got it, right.
"Awe man I can't have Drake
thinking this is corny."
You got eyes.
Before it was your boys, you were like
(screeching)
(chuckles)
and that's how shit happens.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly, yeah.
- Facts.
- This is the time
you need to go into your cocoon
with your little fucking crew
and be like, "Fuck it, let's make pretend
none of this happened. What next?
Let's go eat some cotton candy
and throw up in the pool."
- [Man] That's why people keep asking,
Oh-
- What's next?
- go down to the basement-
- yeah go back to the start shit, yeah.
- [Man] Made you the hottest and shit,
that's what a lot of people say.
- Good. That's good advice.
I believe that. I believe in that.
You can't get high on
your own supply you know.
That's what happens.
- Right.
- You know.
That's what happens.
I see it everyday, that's what happens.
People start acting like they're somebody.
You know what I mean.
Or, actually I'm not
even worried about that,
even just in five seconds of your vibe,
they get crippled to do.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- With shit they used to just post
on a fucking whim,
now you're overthinking, and not posting.
Now you're only posting
when you're with somebody,
you know, you get caught.
- Yeah, corny.
- Yeah, it's not phony, it's cool,
listen it's amazing.
I literally only watch drake's
full fucking music video
to see your part of it.
It's amazing.
It's fucking amazing, it
makes me so happy for you.
It's amazing.
- Definitely.
- Same (mumbles) who text
me. That's the greatest.
But it can't change your process.
- Yeah you're right.
- I don't think of it as
phony, or selling out,
because it's now part of your life.
It's just how do you keep creating.
- [Man] What do you think about
social media platforms evolution?
How long do you think Instagram has?
- I never know, but
it's the right question,
it won't have forever,
so everything you can do to syphen them
in as many places as possible
is good strategy,
but everybody's fucking
going all in on Insta
and then they're gonna
be MySpace celebrities.
(chuckling)
- You gotta do both right.
- I think of Instagram as a
start of a new culture, that's how I feel.
- Listen I'm all about Instagram,
I see nothing that stops it,
until two girls in Texas
tomorrow start an app,
and we can't believe it.
- [Everyone] Yeah.
- You know. I'm with you.
Right now, I'm like Instagram.
- [Shiggy] Yeah Instagram's the shit.
- Yeah if somebody...
If my team was like, "bad news, new law,
gotta delete everything but one platform."
Instagram.
But, I'm always ready for something else.
That's why we have email,
and a text platform,
I'm fucking diverse.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah I see your text platforms.
- I do everything.
I don't want to be at
the mercy of anything.
By the way, Instagram's
gonna be fly as fuck
in two years,
what if it's organic reach
does what Facebook did?
Oh by the way Facebook owns it,
it's what's gonna happen.
So now you get 500,000 a million views.
The same shit, it's all the same,
now you're getting a
hundred thousand views,
doesn't feel as good.
- Yeah.
- That's already happened,
and it's gonna continue to happen.
'Cus they gotta fill that
feed with advertising.
That's Facebook losing
advertising, you know,
Zuck is looking to make his money.
- Yeah facts.
- Right.
- [Man] What do you think is the
next social media's that's coming up?
- [Shiggy] He probably doesn't know right.
- You never know.
I'm pretty good at moving
fast when I see it.
I'm not Nostradamus, predicting shit.
- [Man] You still like Musically?
- With Tok now, not as much.
But it's pretty interesting,
I've been getting asked
a lot about it lately,
so I'm kinda gonna dig
into it a little bit more
and see if there's (mumbles) what.
- [Man] Yeah, I mean it's
definitely still active.
- It's super young.
I mean you should definitely do it.
- Musically I tried too, Tik
Tok is the new thing right.
- [Gary] You should do it.
- Little.
You should...
You eight, nine, seven, you're set.
- [Man] All the young kids-
- [Shiggy] Yeah all the young kids yeah.
- You know how you show up
with rappers, or in culture,
I would look at the
YouTube kid celebrities,
and show up randomly at some slimer girl.
Just be in it and be like (screams).
Like the younger you can get and accepted-
- Yeah exactly the better yeah, the best.
- The more what you guys
want to actually happen
will happen.
- Yeah that's your roots
right there. 'Cus they
grow up and (mumbles).
- [Shiggy] It's so, I
don't know, 'cus it's so...
'Cus what I post, what I do,
it's kinda hard to see...
- Listen I curse my...
I'm really...
And like the reality is,
parents will control that.
- Yeah.
- Like when you go on Garcia's Slime Show,
you're gonna act appropriate.
And if they happen to then follow you
two years later on Instagram,
and they love that you're inappropriate,
then you're set.
- Yeah so yeah.
- That's exactly what you want.
- Exactly.
- (chuckling) Right.
- [Shiggy] Like on some
Disney Channel type shit.
- 100%. Logan Paul was on Disney Channel.
- Yeah. (laughing)
- So ease it up, you
know. (laughing) exactly.
What, anything else in business
that's coming through
you guys, kinda of desk
you're like I'm not sure,
anything I can help with.
What about brand deals?
- Brand deals.
Right now it's mostly about like
getting the brand deals,
and at the same time trynna
price, or value yourself,
or what you
- It's super hard.
- should get for that,
you know what I'm saying.
- [Gary] Well here's the good news.
This is the most basic advice,
but it's true as fuck.
Shoot high as fuck, and
just work backwards.
It's actually crazy, that's the truth.
They're all over the place, you know this.
Hit them with the high is
a very good way to put it.
- [Man] Hit them with the high.
- Actually you know what,
that would be a funny video.
- Yeah, right.
- If an influencer did a
spoof of being an influencer,
trynna hit them with the high.
(laughing)
You got Mr. Pepsi on the line,
"How much you want, 100 thousand?"
You know.
- Yeah.
- I think that, you know,
how I did my speaking.
I went from zero to 5,000.
When I got paid the first time $5,000
to give a speech, I lost my mind.
I probably told every
person I knew in the world.
And now I get (blanked out) for a speech.
I'm like a rapper, that does a show.
And it got there by that model.
The first one was 5,000,
then it was like 10,000, 15,000, you know.
And then the first time
I hit a wall at 25.
I got to 25 and I'm like
"alright, here we go,
I can't wait for the next
one to come in. Yo 35,"
They're like, "naw."
I'm like OK, but I'm
not gonna give up yet.
Next person 35. "Naw."
A couple more people came, I'm like 35.
They're like "naw."
I'm like fuck, I'm 25.
(laughing)
That's literally how I figured it out.
- Yeah that's how you figure it out, yeah.
- You know, that's really
how it actually happened
back in the day.
And then you know you build up,
and some of the followers grow,
you know and then you're like
you stick there for six months,
and get a little more courage.
Something by accident happens,
and then they offer you cold at 40.
And you're like, "Oh I'm 40 now."
That's literally how it happened.
- Alright cool,
so that's pretty much
how it is right now too.
The day you run into people...
'cus like how do you go back with people
who say they paid you the five,
now you're 40-
- shit's different.
You're like, "I wasn't
in fucking Drake's video
when you paid me five."
- Like that's how it goes.
- Like that's just truth,
like when Lebron's rookie contract
doesn't look like it now,
like it's just business.
- Yeah that's all it is.
- Yeah when it go up,
price's up.
- price's up.
Especially with a position
when you wanna say no.
What you need to be smart about,
is stay consistent when you say no,
even when you're postering,
and you guys are...
Like your management, or you,
if you're peacocking a little bit,
and you say no,
and they're like "Fuck we actually
would've taken 35,"
you gotta let it go.
'Cus you can't get that reputation.
People are gonna know.
The market is the biggest
gangster of them all.
- [Man] Especially New York market.
- Just the market.
- Period.
- People know everything.
- People know people talk.
- Right, I always tell street kids,
I'm like it's just like the streets.
Corporate's just like the streets.
They know.
So be smart.
- Yeah.
(laughing)
- You know.
- Then you think you're
trynna outsmart them, but you're not.
- You're not. You're not.
- You're not.
- You're just not.
You can get one off.
Listen it's just like the streets.
You can get something off,
but if you're consistently trying to,
you're gonna get caught, right.
A hundred thousand percent.
A lot of my friends who
I grew up with rugid,
I always tell them, it's the...
It's like well I'm good at it.
It was the same shit.
It's really funny when
you realize it too right.
It's kinda like oh shit.
It makes sense.
You've seen so many people
make that transition
last 20 years in hip hop.
It comes natural. It's the same shit.
- What about after the fact?
After you got the money, you know,
you gotta do the investment aspect.
- Yeah investments' important.
I think the economy is
like super, super bloated,
so I think a lot of people get caught.
I think first things first,
is like core shit,
like do you want to buy a home,
do you wanna like...
You know.
Don't buy dumb shit,
buy like the core shit.
Like a lot of kids and people get put on
will buy like the vanity shit.
And I'm like, "don't do that."
First just get the core fucking thing
that you need.
Buying a home is like a real nice thing.
For you especially you know.
So, yeah investing's important,
but I think right now, a
lot of people don't lose
a lot of money on high risk investing,
and I think things like ap...
Like right now, I'm obsessed
with Facebook stock,
'cus it's down to 140.
I'm like (sighs), I'm super into it.
So, that's gonna be something
I'm gonna invest in pretty soon here.
- [Man] What about (mumbles)?
- I don't know to be honest.
I don't follow it enough
to get you know...
As you can see I really spit it if I know,
but I'm real comfortable
being like I don't know.
For me, it's Netflix, Amazon, Facebook.
It's a wrap.
So to me, I'm not scared to
invest in that long term,
'cus I don't see the competitor
that fucks with them yet.
But like if tomorrow Walmart buys Twitter.
Mhmm that might fuck with Amazon.
You know, so it's always...
People try to guess or predict,
everybody wants to be smart.
- [Man] That's what
they saying about Tesla.
- Tesla's interesting to me
'cus the thing with Tesla
is Elon's a genius,
but he also doesn't give a fuck.
(snickering)
And that's something scary to invest in.
- Yeah.
- Too risky.
- [Man] Tomorrow he (mumbles).
- He's just out of control.
By the way, I love it, I'm the say way
that's why I'm like I'd
be weird to invest it.
I just might retire
tomorrow and garage sell.
- [Man] (mumbles) that's my take on it.
- You know what the problem is,
and I don't intimately know this,
but the thing that it
seems with like Tesla,
at least from the headlines I read,
which is always dangerous,
but the biggest thing people get caught on
is you can't get over leveraged.
You know how much money MC Hammer made.
- 20 mill.
- And you can still be broke.
If you spend 21 million.
So that's what some of these companies...
And I don't know if that's
the case with Tesla,
but definitely startups,
why I stopped investing,
they look good on paper,
but like they're so over leveraged
that if the economy fails,
and they can't raise more money.
When you're losing
money, you're vulnerable.
That's why I built a
company that makes money.
(laughing)
So that's how I think
about a lot of investment
right now is predicated on
companies that lose money,
so that's why...
Especially when you first get the money,
go get an asset that you need, you know,
I don't know any of your stories,
but that's how I think about that.
We've just been a (mumbles) situation
for a long time.
What about merch?
- Yeah I tried shit.
- Yeah we were thinking bout
outsourcing versus making it yourself.
- What do you mean making it yourself?
Are you making a (mumbles) with Adidas
versus you doing your own thing
and selling it direct.
- Yeah.
- If the brand's big enough,
it's a good cosign.
You know I like to keep everything,
but I did K-Swiss.
You know if Kid Robot or Bape
is trynna do something with you,
- You do it, yeah.
So how do you work out numbers with that?
Numbers and percentages with that.
- Depending on the deal,
they're gonna want to give you
some upfront money,
and then they're gonna incentivize you
on how well it sells.
- OK.
- So equity or something.
- Equity if it's a small company.
Spray ground is not giving you equity.
Anything bigger, (beep),
(mumbles) is not giving you equity.
But you know some...
And that's where people get caught.
They're fascinated by equity
so they go with some kid,
who printed like 78 hoodies,
but they own 30%,
you own 30% of nothing.
(laughing)
It's like anything else.
First rodeo.
This is why I love giving love
to people coming up,
'cus it's all the shit I took for...
I had like my dad,
you just gotta go through it.
But that's how I think
about it for me, for you
it's a good look if you get a real brand
people fuck with.
- Yeah dope.
- You're still coming up.
People are still trying to figure out
what-
- Place you in, exactly.
- So, Champion, it's a good look.
They do something with you
limited edition thousand.
Cool.
I went completely different.
I did something with K Swiss,
which was corny, but I
knew it had real swag
back in the day.
And I have an engine to really reboot it,
and now I get extra credit.
- Yeah that clout.
- And so people are chirping,
which gives me leverage.
It wasn't K Swiss put me on,
I put K Swiss on.
- Yeah exactly, yeah.
- You do something with Champion,
Champion put you on.
Make sense.
- Yeah you gotta find
a brand that you gotta-
- But when I had as many followers as you
in my moments,
I didn't have the machine,
all these characters,
company, thousand people,
K Swiss is not just me on social media,
running ads, doing partnerships, you know.
- Yeah it's a lot.
- You guys are still in the early days,
so take that check and that upside,
and that look.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- [Man] Yeah 'cus nowadays
other than the money
it's about your look.
- 100% right. I'm (mumbles)
having a Nike matters.
- Yeah it's great, it does, 100%.
- 100%.
Again that's why I did mines.
I wanted to be like yo,
let me prove to everybody
how real legit I am.
I'm gonna get people to
give a fuck about K Swiss.
And for the OG cats they love it,
especially the West Coast guys.
'Cus that's really where it was popping.
They're like damn, you know,
- Like K Swiss.
You got them on now right.
I didn't even see them
drop them (mumbles).
- The black ones I'm dropping
at complexcon this weekend.
You're gonna be there.
- [Man] Yeah we're gonna be there.
- Then we'll chop.
- I see you talking right.
- What are we do Karen (mumbles)?
- Yeah.
- Is she fire side chatting me?
It's not coach...
She's interviewing me.
- [Man] I believe so, yes.
- Triple check.
- Alright.
- That's gonna be fresh,
I think this year is gonna be cool.
- [Man] Your talk last
year was one of the best.
- I'm always best when
I'm in that environment.
When I'm in the culture, I'm just like
so much happy.
(laughing)
- [Man] (mumbles) talk to you
for four hours about (mumbles)
and then you just went on stage
and spit it back out at everybody.
- Oh right. Go ahead (mumbles).
- [Man] Are you originally from New York?
- I was born in Russia.
I lived my first two years in Queens.
When I was like four or five.
I remember it, but not really.
Then I went to Dover,
which I never...
I gotta start giving Dover more love.
I was in Dover, Jersey for a year,
but I really grew up in Edison.
Really interesting we posted
my second grade picture,
and I didn't even realize it,
'cus I found it on Facebook
from another classmate,
what a great time to be in Edison.
That was a crazy picture.
The diversity, like Asian,
Indian, Black, White,
right.
Some guy left the best Instagram comment,
he's like "(mumbles) I see you
hanging with all the rappers
tryna get your black card," he's like,
"why don't you just tell everybody
that you went to Martin Luther
King elementary school,"
like motherfucker.
(laughing)
I was laughing for so long.
Yeah I'm very East Coast,
and what's really
interesting is because Edison
was so diverse, when
Run DMC and Beastiboys,
when hip hop was kinda...
Not, I wasn't Sugar Hill
Gang, or something like that,
but when it was starting to,
just about get going, I was really in it.
But really, really, it was college,
when I went to a 90%
African American college
where I really kinda-
- What school was that?
- Mount Eda College in New Mass.
Ghetto as fuck.
(laughing)
I slept with my wallet.
- [Man] What made you base
your business out of New York?
- The New York Jets.
I have to go to Jet games
so, I'll never move.
(laughing)
I'm being dead serious, it's really funny.
I really fall in love with L.A a bunch,
but I'm always like naw,
I gotta live in New York,
my whole family's here.
- [Man] What advice
would you give somebody
that's tryna start a business.
- A lot of different piece of advices.
Like first of all, don't be ideological,
or romantic, or gas each other up.
Be practical.
- Yeah (mumbles) sucks.
- Yeah, yeah.
Do something you really like.
Not because you think there's money it.
All these kids chasing cryptocurrency
or all this other stuff,
they're in it for the money,
they don't love it.
I love what I do, which is
why I'm always successful.
And when I don't love it,
I fucking start changing.
Like love it...
You know why, when you're coming from zero
or not a lot, you have to work a lot.
Nobody talks about that shit.
You can make pretend you're
an entrepreneur on Instagram
But like to start a business,
you wanna build an actual business.
Like you'd like it to be successful.
And so what are you good at?
Are you good at sales?
What are you selling?
What do you like?
Scratch your own itch, I'm big on that.
Like I wish there was an ice cream
that was peanut flavored with...
I love when people make shit,
that they wanted.
I love that, I call it,
scratch your own itch.
Like what would you like
to exist, that doesn't.
- Then make it.
- That's a great idea
for a business.
'Cus you love it, and a lot of times
that's why it pops.
Spanks, Sarah Blakely she drilled it,
like I need this, fucking made it.
Lot of other women needed it.
Listening.
One thing about social
that's really incredible
is you can listen.
So listening is good to figure out,
'cus everyone's just postering
and fronting you know.
So like practical, patience, you're...
How old are you?
- 24.
(scoffs)
- You be like, "cool I
want to start a business."
You need to be like, "OK at
32 I can pull my head up."
But everyone's like at 25,
I gonna make a million.
That's what 24 year olds do.
That's what 99% of 24 year olds do.
- That's true though,
'cus I do say that too.
- [Man] I say that too though.
I be like, "When I turn 25,
(mumbles).
- 100%
and then all bad behavior.
I was like 29, 28 years old packing boxes
in a liquor store.
That's my career.
You got time, you know.
I turn 43 in two weeks.
And I feel like we're
friends in the same age.
I know I'm not, but when you get there,
you'll feel this way too.
When I was 24, my cousin was 32,
I thought he was dead.
(laughing)
100% I remember it.
It's not that long ago...
Your memories are good.
You remember when you were 15.
When I was 24, I thought 32 was ancient.
So I know what you're feeling.
And I'm here telling you
42 is the same as 24.
And when you realize
that, you get patient.
And patience has been a huge factor
in why I've been successful.
If you try to take that quick bag,
but it fucks up your brand,
you're gonna lose.
So the key is when things
start popping like this,
to almost triple down on being humble.
I built my dad's liquor store
from a three to a 60
million dollar business,
and I was paying myself less sometimes
than the year prior, going out never.
All these club guys that are like
running shit in New York now,
they like think I'm
cool and we're friends,
they were like, "where were you?"
I'm like, "I didn't come to New York."
But they were like, "but
you were in Jersey."
I'm like, I worked every
Friday and Saturday night.
They're like, "No."
They don't even believe me.
Head down, make content, build community.
I'd rather you literally lay in bed
for 14 hours a day,
and DM and reply to every one of your DMs
than almost anything else you would do.
'Cus that's gonna make
your fan base sticky.
- That might get me in trouble too.
- Yes you gotta be careful.
(laughing)
Make sure you give your girl access,
but make your audience sticky.
- [Man] How do you feel about
friends and business?
- That's a great fucking question too man,
you're on fire.
(laughing)
My brother and dad...
My dad was my partner in wine business,
my brother was a partner in this,
so family business is similar to the way
I think about friends.
Mike Boyd is friends with AJ,
we had a lot of AJ's
friends in this business.
Six years later, Marcus was number three
in the company, others were number 200.
So merit played out,
which is why we got away with it.
But what you're talking bout...
Me and my dad, more
than me and my brother,
you know my brother very easily,
but me and my dad
we just loved each other a hair more than
the business and the money,
and we always did what was
right for the business.
Dude it's gonna be hard.
If this really pops off,
you guys are gonna have stuff.
And the more you can
talk about the stuff now,
instead of making pretend
it won't happen to you,
the more likely you'll be
able to get through it.
Some of the late nights when you guys
are grinding and traveling,
instead of like, just have
something good happen,
you have an appearance,
whatever, Good Morning America,
or a fucking rap concert appearance,
taking that drive back,
and being like, "yo what's gonna happen
when this really pops.
When an agent makes a call
that doesn't feel right."
Just even starting to practice
when you're not gonna be aligned,
is a good idea.
Even just weird shit...
Here's a weird idea,
"yo let's make a pack,
where everybody puts their hands in,
every January 2nd, day after New Years,
we go out to this dinner,
even if we didn't talk to each other
in the six months prior,"
I'm being serious with you,
"because one of us stole money
from somebody."
Like let's just play it out.
By just doing that, you
see where I'm going.
Like create a framework of truth
that gives you a chance
to have your relationship.
You see where I'm going.
- [Man] It's harder sometimes
when it's friends and it's family,
you know what I'm saying,
you can't let your dad not be your dad.
- Yeah but you know what's funny,
you pick your friends though.
- [Man] Yeah always.
- You know, I get you,
and some people depending
on how they were raised
and shit like that.
Like have the worst mom and dad,
but still likes my mom and dad.
But on the flip side you
guys picked each other.
- [Man] I look at it
like this, my first...
It's so crazy I was talking
to my moms the other day
right and I was telling her my friends is
like my family.
- For real.
- [Man] And I say that 'cus we been around
each other for so long.
- That trust is so real.
- [Man] I'm around my friends
more than I'm around my family.
- Not even close.
Friends are real, real, real.
But money changes shit,
and don't be naive.
And that's OK.
Some of you is gonna fall in love,
girls bring new fucking...
(laughing)
Shit happens.
Somebody's mom gets sick.
Somebody felt slighted
because in an interview
you mentioned three of
them, but not the fourth,
and that's all-
(laughing)
Two minutes.
- [Man] That's real,
that's real life though.
- This is why people fuck with me,
I tell the truth,
you already laughed at two things
that are actually really happening.
Get ahead of it.
Don't try to be tough guys,
and suppress it, 'cus
you're gonna get caught,
and then you're not gonna
have that friendship.
You turn it...
You know what it does,
it makes you own the situation,
instead of the situation owning you.
Because when it happens,
then you're all back at the crib,
making a joke about fuck
we said this would happen.
You fucked me up, I'm mad at you,
then you're like I'm so sorry, kiss,
then you know, you own it,
instead of it owning you.
Communication.
- Facts.
- [Man] One more question,
would you employ your friend
over an outsider?
- Always.
I love employing friends.
But since I was always top dog,
I always told friends,
I'll fire you I swear, 'cus
I'll help you get a job better
but you can't fuck up the thing,
and you can't be entitled.
And I'm a human and I may be wrong,
I may decide that Boyd better than D-rock,
I may be wrong,
but this is my shit.
You (mumbles) your shit.
So if you want to be employed here,
I'm gonna try my best, I got love,
I want to all die together,
but yeah, we started this company
with like seven friends.
I took my assistant from (mumbles)
the only person, and it was like
six of AJ's friends,
and we started.
I love that shit,
I'm like very Jersey (mumbles) school.
I'm much more like that.
Old school shit.
What's better than this,
but there's always gonna be that moment.
And the more you can
start talking bout it now,
there's gonna be moments between people,
you're gonna be like
"Oh fuck who do I pick,"
just shit.
It's OK, just talk more now.
'cus it's gonna make it feel less,
- Yeah tense.
- Same reason you laughed
when I stumbled on one
that's already happened,
let it be that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah it's better to keep
it true, keep it honest.
It's better for him than anything.
- Is that signed?
- Which one, Carmelo?
- Yeah.
- That's my guy.
I love Carmelo, I hate
that he gets shitted on
he's super smart,
and people forget who Carmelo really was,
people forget about athletes
when they get older.
- Yeah exactly.
- He was a fucking
[Both] Beast.
He was too strong for the league.
- He was.
- He was,
he put that whole Denver team on his back.
Too strong for the league,
and this was before Super teams.
Real easy to be a superstar
when you got four other
superstars with you.
(laughing)
Cool I gotta go.
(shaking hands)
Real pleasure man.
- Yeah man.
- Real pleasure man.
- Alright man.
- Thanks man.
- You're welcome of course,
real pleasure.
Let's take a photo.
(upbeat music)